I want to say thank you for making Chris
Hogan's everyday millionaires book an
absolute blowout success people wanting
to learn about what everyday
millionaires look like the book has is
the result of a study that Chris and our
rimsey research team did study doing the
largest study of American millionaires
that's ever been done and we discovered
where millionaires really come from we
know a lot about them there's a hundred
and forty statistics in the book it is
not a research paper if you're a super
nerd and you're looking for a white
paper on the research project that's not
what this is but it does have a hundred
and forty stats in it things like
seventy-nine percent of millionaires
inherited zero five percent inherited
less than 100 thousand another five
percent less than two hundred thousand
which mathematically means that around
90% of America's millionaires nine out
of ten did not receive enough
inheritance to become a millionaire they
did it on their own only 1% actually
inherited a million dollars or more
there's 12 million millionaires in North
America if you want to be a millionaire
you need to learn what millionaires do
and do what they do if you want to be
skinny learn what skinny people do and
do what they do if you want to grow hair
on top of your head don't do what I did
it didn't work well so you got you know
you have to look at things that are
winning if you've been divorced 14 times
I'll pray for your next marriage but I'm
not reading your book on marriage you're
a marriage loser you been married 67
years I want to sit down and talk to you
how'd you stay married to her she and
kill you that long because there's times
I think I'm gonna wake up dead married
to this hillbilly woman I'm just saying
so you know here's that's the deal folks
I mean
finds it's called best practices in
business find out abound of business is
winning in marketing and study their
marketing find a business is winning in
their
development study their product
development processes it's best
practices find out what rich people are
doing and do rich people's stuff now
some people are so stupid I tweeted that
the other day
the rich people stuff you bet to get to
be rich people you do poor people stuff
you get to be poor people if you're poor
people you did rich people stuff long
enough you get to be rich people if
you're rich people and you do poor
people stuff long enough you're poor
people but some people are so stupid
that you think rich people stuff is
going and buying things you can't afford
it doesn't mean that at all that's dumb
rich people don't do that they buy stuff
they can afford meaning they pay cash
for it they avoid debt 74% of the
millionaire's we talked to have never
carried a dime of credit card net Wow
I mean you can't be a millionaire if you
got credit card debt no it just means
you're not likely to ever become one if
you continue to carry it think about
that
they don't borrow money for anything for
that matter
very very very debt averse the average
millionaire that we studied was 49 years
old and you know you have to be 49 to be
a millionaire no we talked to a whole
lot of them in their 20s 30s we studied
over 10,000 of them I'm intrigued with
these statistics because I just act
we're writing a white paper they're
doing the actual research paper on it
that we're going to publish just for the
fun of it because there's a bunch of
yous they're super nerds like me and I
just finished reading it it's gonna be
about 50 pages long and it is boring as
crud I mean I just about fell asleep in
my chair this morning finishing it it is
boring but it's all of a detail the fine
detail the statistical analysis of the
research that we did and some of you
were going to want to read that that's
fun but every day millionaires for
regular people this is the fried buck to
read because it's got the inspiration
that it's got the stories in it and it's
got the statistical evidence of the
largest study of millionaires ever done
and it's a number one bestseller no
kidding of course it is every day
millionaires by Chris Hogan now I'm
telling you all that because if you will
do rich
people stuff you get to be rich people
what is rich people stuff I just told
you they don't sit around and wait on an
inheritance because one's not coming oh
they didn't go to prestige schools no
hardly any of them eight percent went to
a name school most of them did get an
education though a lot of them did
graduate work but not in left handed
puppetry or gender studies or getting a
PhD in German polka history they got a
degree in something that was actually
usable in the marketplace oh by the way
their continual learners 97% of the
millionaires said that they control
their own destiny more than
circumstances do not to say
circumstances didn't impact them that's
not what I said but 97% said they
control their own destiny by the way
when we stayed the general public you
know what they said
62% thought they control their own
destiny but 97% that's all of them
well the millionaire's think that by and
large you control your own destiny it's
very offensive to left wing nut jobs to
say that you lefties it's very offensive
to you to say that you control your own
destiny because you want a you know a
universal minimum wage you want
socialism you want to feel the Bern you
want someone else to do your life for
you instead of controlling your own
distance to being responsible for your
own destiny now the right-wing nut jobs
have other problems but the left wing
nut jobs have their set of problems and
boy have we gotten some hate over this
book even that one little tweet I put
out this morning a lot of hate people
get political in a heartbeat this has
nothing to do with politics but your
politics are usually formed by your
worldview or vice versa
sometimes your worldview is formed by
your politics which makes you completely
shallow but you know do some critical
thought and just say okay the reality is
regardless of
belief system regardless of what you
were told or what your party told you
are what the talking points on your
particular favorite channel are PERTs
aside from that think for yourself and
say well the largest research study and
it's listen it's double-blind it's set
up every research technique was employed
this thing is airtight the research
technique is not in question it was not
a it was not a shill of a study it's set
up very carefully because we knew we
were gonna be criticized I mean we
bolted this thing down tight there is no
leaks in it if you really key if you
want to argue with the results of the
study you're what's known as wrong 97%
of millionaires think it's up to them
deliver yourself like a gazelle from the
hand of the hunter deliver yourself